大家好，我是Sam，PlanetScale的CEO。我们是一家云数据库公司，为全球一些最成功的科技产品托管着一些最大的数据库。我们有三项主要服务。
Vites，就是分片MySQL；Niki，分片Postgres；还有PlanetScale Postgres，这是全球最快的Postgres托管服务，运行在我们自己的金属服务器上。基础设施一直是我整个职业生涯的痴迷所在，我热爱支持那些改变世界、为杰出人才创造价值的产品。
比如，Cursor就是PlanetScale的客户，我非常自豪他们能在PlanetScale上运行非常庞大的分片数据库。他们在改变世界，能参与其中真的非常了不起。
我的演讲主题是：智能体如何改变了基础设施的角色，以及这种变化将如何持续演进，基础设施又该如何向智能体提供简明扼要的指令和洞察，让它们能够安全地操作基础设施，不造成任何损害，在真实环境中完成工作。
而且，即便发生了意外，任何差错都可以被撤销。所以，我的演示会使用智能体。这是一个特别的会议，庆祝一个特别的产品，我想让这次演讲与众不同，所以几乎全程与智能体协同完成。
你们看到的每张幻灯片也都是用Cursor开发的。重要的是要记住，智能体是非确定性的，每次我演练这个演示，它都会做出不同的举动，但最终总能达成目标。
而且，我们是在一个设计得极为安全的系统上构建。PlanetScale是高可用服务，所以它可能会直接阻止我们的操作，让智能体停下来，至少我们会看到这样的情况。
我们听过很多关于数据库和智能体交互的可怕故事，现在我们将看到另一面。我们现在就开始，先启动一个演示，因为这需要一些时间，然后我会带你参观这个产品。
刚才你扫了二维码，会看到SFM Mart，这是我为创业者开的店。网站很慢，但我们卖的都是好东西，适合搬到旧金山创业的人。不过，性能真的开始拖后腿了，订单量也受影响了。
你看，这里我们设置了Grafana，这个站点托管在Cloudflare上。可以看到订单率还行，我们做得还行，但查询速度真的很慢，平均查询时间……”
店是给创始人开的，确实慢，但我们卖的货很棒，专门给来旧金山创业的人。但现在性能真的开始影响订单量了。
我的网站能接收的订单有限。你可以看到，我们设置了Grafana，这是一个托管在Cloudflare上的实时站点。订单率看着还行，我们还在正常运营，但查询耗时确实很高，平均查询时间远超正常水平。
差不多要四秒，最慢能到五秒，这可不妙。我们知道，要是产品太慢，用户就会放弃结账。这个数据库就托管在PlanetScale上，只是一个简单的三节点集群。
然后我们有个小工具，可以实时看到智能体在忙什么。我们现在想让数据库提速，所以打开Cursor，开始第一个演示。我就是让智能体去检查一下PlanetScale有没有什么优化建议，然后照着执行，顺便优化一下代码库，看看效果如何。
我现在就启动它，它马上会开始规划行动。就像我说的，我们待会儿能看到性能上的变化和差异。
我们现在看智能体的视角，一旦它们跑起来，就能看到它们怎么一路狂奔、开始干活，瞧瞧它们在搞什么名堂。
我们想展示现代基础设施平台的安全特性和各种机制。我们还故意塞了一些指令，让智能体可能犯错，希望它们跑起来的时候咱们能看到这些情况。
看，它已经开始列出模式更改，准备派生出子智能体了。它们随时会冒出来，而网站还是特别慢，一切照旧。我们还有负载和订单在继续生成。
我们等等看，它正在验证状态，看吧，这是非确定性的，只能耐心等它们准备好开始干活。现在它已经开始编辑、运行，读取PlanetScale API了。
主智能体马上会把任务分发给几个子智能体。所有东西都跑在Composer 2.5上，我们这儿构建的几乎都是，运行飞快，才能实现这种并行处理。好了，子智能体们开工了。
谢天谢地，子智能体们跑起来了。看，它们正在干活呢。这些可爱的小机器人正在经历各个阶段，探索PlanetScale为它们准备的各种信息。PlanetScale会生成洞察报告。
你可以看到，它会推荐各种数据库改动。这个原本是为人设计的，但现在对智能体也特别好用，我们会带入大量上下文，尽量解释清楚发生了什么，指出需要编辑哪些查询。
我们还会建议改表结构。我们有自己的模型，会实际测试索引建议，看看性能提升效果，然后生成推荐。我们会建议删掉一些索引，或者提醒你整数空间快用完了，这些以前都得靠数据库工程师手工处理。
这些都是实实在在需要处理的数据库问题，现在全都自动化了，我们有了这些自主的“工程师”——也就是智能体，它们能搞定这些活儿。
我们看到它们正在执行任务，跑得飞快，我们也跟着推进。接下来咱们去看看这些智能体具体做了些什么。
它们已经完成了。所以，就像我说的，这已经用于部署这些模式变更，添加我们讨论过的索引。我们能够确切地看到正在更改的内容。这就是我们所说的部署请求。所以，PlanetScale允许你分支你的数据库。分支旨在为你提供一个类似生产的环境，以便进行更改。你可以在这些分支上进行模式更改。当你准备好部署它们时，你就创建所谓的部署请求。嗯，
Scale让你能分支数据库。分支是为了给你一个接近生产的环境来做更改。你可以在那些分支上做模式更改。当你准备部署时，就创建一个部署请求。嗯，
它正在移动，正在制作，并且已经部署。你可以确切地看到模式中发生了什么变化。在我们的洞察和图表中，我们甚至有一条漂亮的线条显示那一刻的变化。现在，这真的很有用，考虑到在这个现代世界里，你会让智能体随时间让基础设施变得更好。你确切想知道正在发生什么，对吧？必须知道，没有什么比凌晨两点被叫醒更糟糕的了，生产环境坏了，而你完全不知道原因。我们关联所有变更，包括异常、错误和问题，覆盖你能看到的每个图表。然后我们确切地显示查询及其运行频率。
考虑到在当今世界，你会有智能体不断优化你的基础设施，这非常有用。你确切想知道发生了什么，对吧？必须得知道。凌晨两点被叫起来，生产环境挂了，你完全不知情，那太糟糕了。我们把所有变更、异常、错误和问题关联起来，分布在你看到的每个图表上。然后我们精确展示查询内容以及运行频率。
凌晨两点被叫醒，生产环境出问题，你完全不知情。我们将所有变更、异常、错误和问题关联到你能看到的每个图表上。然后我们精确展示查询内容以及运行频率。所以你可以看到这一定是订单查询。对，它快多了。我们已经在Grafana里看到了。我们大幅降低了该查询的性能（此处应为提升了性能，但按原文翻译）。我们已经通过这里的火花线发布了结果。
它们运行。所以你可以看到这一定是订单查询。是的，它变得更快了。我们已经能在Grafana里看到了。那个查询的性能大幅改善。我们还在那里发布了线条。抱歉，是线条，方便观察网站移动得更快了。让我们看看我们的智能体视图在做什么。哦，好。所以这是一个“坏”智能体，它卡住了，而这都是我在操作。但我们拒绝了丢弃一列，因为那会中断进行中的查询。所以PlanetScale所做的是查看你所有的进行中查询，检查部署请求是否会破坏数据库中的任何活动查询，然后禁止你执行，除非你明确强制通过。但我们已经成功阻止了一个智能体破坏生产环境。太棒了。对确定性来说是好消息。太棒了。我们添加了缺失的索引。谢谢。谢谢。嗯，呃，所以是的，我们还在继续工作。我们看到部署请求在发生。分支被创建和合并，我们的网站变得更快。我们在Grafana上看到了。我们的订单量更稳定了。嗯，我们每秒查询数上升了。这是一个非常好的变化。我真的很高兴。好的，让我们看看还有什么在发生。所以，我们有另一个智能体在正常工作。你可以看到这些都是真实的，对吧？他们一直在做他们的工作。这些都是真实发生的事情，正在达成目标。我们重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了缺失的索引。这是我们要做的。
线条也在那里。呃，抱歉，类似于线条，让我们看到网站移动得更快了。让我们看看我们的智能体视图在做什么。哦，好。所以这是其中一个“坏”智能体，它卡住了，而这都是我在操作。但我们拒绝了丢弃一列，因为那会中断进行中的查询。所以PlanetScale做的是查看所有正在发生的查询，检查部署请求是否会破坏数据库中的任何活动查询，然后禁止执行，除非你明确强制通过。但我们已经成功阻止了一个智能体破坏生产环境。
但我们拒绝了删除一列，因为那会破坏正在进行的查询。PlanetScale所做的是，它会查看你所有正在运行的查询，检查部署请求是否会破坏数据库中任何活跃的查询，只是不允许你执行，除非你显然强制通过。嗯，但我们已经成功阻止了智能体破坏生产。那很棒。对确定性来说是好消息。太棒了。我们已经添加了缺失的索引。谢谢。谢谢。嗯，呃，所以是的，我们还在继续工作。我们看到部署请求发生。分支被创建和合并，我们的网站变得更快。我们能在Grafana上看到。我们的订单量稍微更稳定了。嗯，我们每秒查询数上升了。这真是一个很棒的变化。我真的很高兴。好的，让我们看看还有什么。所以，我们有另一个智能体正在工作。你可以看到这些全都是真实的，对吧？他们一直在做他们的工作。这全都是真实发生的事情，并且正在实现其目标。我们已经重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了缺失的索引。这是我们要做的。
在数据库中活跃的查询，并且只是不允许你这样做，除非你显然强制通过。嗯，但我们已经成功阻止了一个智能体破坏生产。那很棒。对确定性来说是好消息。太棒了。我们已经添加了缺失的索引。谢谢。谢谢。嗯，呃，所以是的，我们还在继续工作。我们看到部署请求发生。分支被创建和合并，我们的网站变得更快。我们能在Grafana上看到。我们的订单量稍微更稳定了。嗯，我们每秒查询数上升了。这真是一个很棒的变化。我真的很高兴。好的，让我们看看还有什么。所以，我们有另一个智能体正在工作。你可以看到这些全都是真实的，对吧？他们一直在做他们的工作。这全都是真实发生的事情，并且正在实现其目标。我们已经重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了缺失的索引。这是我们要做的。
添加了缺失的索引。谢谢。谢谢。嗯，呃，所以是的，我们还在继续工作。我们看到部署请求发生。分支被创建和合并，我们的网站变得更快。我们能在Grafana上看到。我们的订单量稍微更稳定了。嗯，我们每秒查询数上升了。这真是一个很棒的变化。我真的很高兴。好的，让我们看看还有什么。所以，我们有另一个智能体正在工作。你可以看到这些全都是真实的，对吧？他们一直在做他们的工作。这全都是真实发生的事情，并且正在实现其目标。我们已经重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了缺失的索引。这是我们要做的。
一致。嗯，我们每秒查询数上升了。这里有一个真正的很好的变化。我真的很高兴。好的，让我们看看还有什么。所以，我们有另一个智能体正在工作。你可以看到这些全都是真实的，对吧？他们一直在做他们的工作。这全都是真实发生的事情，并且正在实现其目标。我们已经重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了缺失的索引。这是我们要做的。
都是真实的，对吧？他们一直在做他们的工作。这全都是真实发生的，并且正在达成目标。我们已经重写了一组查询。嗯，我们删除了冗余索引。我们添加了缺失的索引。而这是我们要做的。
现在这个智能体正在做一个我们想要破坏的更改，我们来看看Curson上它是怎么运作的。它正在运行一个冒烟测试，我们给它几秒钟时间完成。所以这个智能体真的会被允许把一些糟糕的东西推到生产环境中。
然后你会看到它真的这么做了，我们失去了对一列的访问权限，这很糟糕，而且我们的网站也加载不了了。PlanetScale的特别之处在于我们能回滚这些更改。
所以，我们刚刚删除了一列，生产环境中已经有表的新版本，但自那以后我们一直在以中间态写入数据。因此，恢复这一列通常是很困难的，对吧？
在99%的数据库中，你现在就得在生产环境恢复数据，还得确保数据继续写入主数据库，如果一切正常的话，你得取回一个版本和快照来恢复服务。
但有了PlanetScale，我们实际上不用这么做。我们保持一个长时间运行的窗口，允许我们回滚到之前的schema版本而不会丢失任何数据。所以我现在要点击那个按钮，而且这非常非常快，无论schema变更有多大，所需时间都一样。
客户经常在100TB甚至更大的表上进行schema变更，我们见过600到700TB的表通过这种方式修改，而且它依然能用同样的方式回滚。
而且我们刚刚非常快地解除了可能持续数小时的严重故障。这样安全性就让智能体们去干活了。这是智能体的视角，它们都完成了任务，坏人都被阻止了，我们拯救了世界，现在我们的网站更快了。
好的，谢谢。你们可以看到快速查询对页面加载的重要性，对吧？你的产品越受欢迎，它就越慢。你看这个瀑布流，要让页面加载出去，如果查询越来越慢，那就会降低我们产品的体验，没人想要那样。
现在我们有更快的查询了，我们成功了，但同时也增加了网站需求，更多的需求意味着数据库更多的负载。从根本上说，我们需要处理更多的查询，所以我们要对数据库进行分片。
所以这是我们当前的问题，对吧？我们有三个数据库服务器，一个主库和两个副本，用来保存我们的订单表和整个数据库的副本，支撑我们的应用。这两个副本的职责就是保持主库中数据的副本。
这两个副本也可以在失去主库时用于故障转移，以实现高可用性，并且真正地有一份副本，这样如果我们失去主库，也不会丢失任何数据。但我们需要更多容量，我们已经达到了垂直扩展的极限，所以需要对数据库进行分片。
对于不知道的人来说，分片是一件非常难以实现的事情。它基本上允许你将单个数据集拆分到许多数据库集群中，每一个都是完全封装的数据库集群。
它基本上让你能把单个数据集分解到很多数据库集群中去，每一个集群都是独立封装的数据库集群。
每个分片都有自己的主节点和副本节点，分布在不同可用区。主节点和副本节点都不在同一可用区，这样分片带来的弹性就大大增强了。比如我们可能丢失主节点，
也可能丢失副本节点，但最多只是丢掉一部分数据，整个数据库对外仍然是一个整体。应用仍然以为自己在连接一个单一的数据库，访问一份连续的数据集，但实际上我们已经在运行一个
分布式系统，复杂度和特性都大大增加了。接下来我们马上要开始分片演示，我会在数据库层面讲解分片过程中的操作。你们可以
实时看到状态更新。我们会展示分片执行过程。第一步是排队等待，准备就绪后部署变更。我们会运行所有PlanetScale的预检查
确保一切正常，然后进入数据复制阶段。光是分片和数据迁移我就能讲两个小时。我们把一个数据库集群中的整套数据，
分布到16个分片上，并在迁移过程中保持同步。我们还会进行复制。因为新数据会不断进来，我们不能简单恢复备份就完事，否则备份之后的数据就全丢了。
我们需要复制，持续不断地复制。然后还要验证，对两个数据库中的每一行做校验和，确保数据完全一致，这样才能保证
不丢失任何数据。接下来我们要切换副本节点。在应用中切换读请求风险较小，PlanetScale会自动处理副本的切换。如果应用
直接访问副本节点，PlanetScale会将读请求导向分片集群的对应副本，应用无需任何改动。然后我们对主节点做同样的操作。这是一个更大的变更，不是
单向操作，实际上我们还可以回退到单一集群。我们反转复制方向，这同样很难操作。现在我们有16条独立的复制流，把它们合并起来再复制回未分片的数据库。
然后分片就完成了。数据分布在16个分片上，一切正常。分片过程中还有一个最困难的部分。我见过有些公司的分片项目
耗时三到四年。这需要大量的代码重构。我会解释为什么，并深入探讨Cursor在这个演示中扮演的角色。首先，我就说一句：现在让我们给这个数据库分片。非常简单。
就这样。实际上非常困难。我早年曾在GitHub工作，当时我写过一个issue，说要尽量避免分片，因为直到现在分片都是
极其困难的。现在我们在看分片需要做什么准备。接下来我们要讨论应用层面的事情。也许我需要刷新一下，看看底部会不会显示出来。
哦，可能不会加载了。看看它会不会马上推送数据。是的，好了，工作流在运行了。谢天谢地。现在你能看到它在排队处理不确定性问题。好的。
第一个要素，这不只是PlanetScale的演示，我们是在用PlanetScale平台展示这些基础能力。我相信未来每个基础设施平台都需要构建这些基础能力。
这只是一个实际应用，而且数据库是极其严肃的。如果我们能在数据库上做到，那其他任何地方都可以。第一件事是vSchema，PlanetScale通过它
知道如何告诉Vitess分片策略、分片位置和数据定位方式。这很酷，因为它是声明式的，允许智能体来构建这个vSchema。这是一个示例vSchema，智能体
会根据PlanetScale技能库中的知识构建出这个或非常类似的东西。我们告诉它这是一个分片数据库，应用一个vindex，也就是哈希，这样数据能均匀分布，
并且每次查询都能找到相同的数据。然后我们定义vindexes，决定按什么键分片。这时候你真的需要团队协作或了解产品，并有能力
重构代码来理解这一点。大多数公司都有一个天然的分片键，比如Shopify按商店分片。实际上有很多选择，但选对分片键
非常重要，我稍后会解释原因。你可以看到我们已经开始复制了，很好。Vitess正在按我们的要求工作。我还可以展示，目前应用完全不受影响，它已经开始
这个工作流，但应用运行得很好。我们决定按items和orders表分片，这是我们最大的表，而且我们还需要引用products表。这就是
重构变得至关重要的地方，这也是为什么Cursor承担了很多工作。我们现在需要改变应用执行join的方式，因为我们会在orders表上join products表。Vitess
会为我们做一点魔术：它会把products表物化到每个分片上。这样一旦到了分片，我们就能在products表上做join。如果你现在在旧版本中执行这个查询，
在旧集群上，应用只需要一个简单的查询就能得到想要的数据。但如果在分片集群上，就要执行所谓的“散射聚集”查询。你可以看到，它会把请求分发到每个分片，然后再汇总回来。
把结果物化。对于数据库来说，这样做虽然可行，也不算太糟，但在关键路径上这么干又慢又不够优化。因为我们要跨节点协调，还要聚合数据。
然后返回给客户端。这正是Cursor大显身手的地方，比如大规模重构。你可能需要把一个用了十年的应用翻个遍，给每个查询加上客户ID，改变所有调用路径，避免散射聚集。
你看到我们在这里加客户ID，因为我们知道怎么分片的，这样就能直接定位到正确的分片上的订单表，不再需要散射聚集了。
直接访问一个分片并返回结果。但如果是一个老应用，要达到这个状态需要大量重构，还要仔细审查所有的调用点。这正是Cursor在这个演示中正在做的事情。
我们回到vitest工作流，可以看到正在执行。我们已经添加了新的路由规则，并运行这个工作流。它在复制数据，记录操作，非常安全。现在它开始切换副本流量。
关于基础设施，我们趁它运行的时候来聊聊。真实产品非常复杂。行业一直过分关注“创建”那一刻，我们可以快速构建东西，比如能快速启动的沙盒数据库。
但未来不在于此。创建只发生一次，一旦完成就完了。真正的挑战在于应用的长期演进。有些应用是跨十年构建的，我们日常接触的产品往往有近二十年历史。
你看，分片完成了。让我们回到这里确认一切正常。我们的应用开始工作了，希望我们能提高订单量。看，订单量猛增，我们显著提高了查询处理速率，因为现在工作负载分布在整个分片集群上。
看，订单量猛增。我们显著提高了查询处理速率，因为现在工作负载分布在整个分片集群上。分片完成，我们有了一个分片的PlanetScale集群。
分片完成，我们有了一个分片的PlanetScale集群。我们早在智能体出现之前就构建了PlanetScale，而且我们是为最不稳定的智能体——人类——构建的。我们这样做是因为人类必须操作数据库，所以我们默认就把它做得非常安全。
然后我们转向为智能体构建，它们的速度更快。有了这些安全防护，智能体可以放手去做。我们遵循Unix哲学，使用小而锐利的工具。工具越窄，歧义越少，可靠性越高。
组合可以扩展智能，而不增加风险。小而可组合的组件，加上窄接口，就能实现安全。我们可以用简单的工具链来替代复杂的决策，让智能体去构建。
这些是我们构建的一些工具，但只是例子。我相信未来每个基础设施平台都需要做这些事情。你可以用它们完成各种任务，比如查看推荐、为CI创建分支，但这并不意味着每次用分支都得做模式变更。
我们有在线模式变更，你可以回滚、产生异常。所有这些都来自后台的一个大型平台。我们必须运行庞大的数据处理管道和数据仓库，来处理每秒数千万次的查询。
把数据带进来，分析每次查询的长期性能，提出建议。基础设施平台需要在水平面以下构建大量的基础设施，以支持与智能体协作，扩展这种专业知识。一个我喜欢的例子是流量控制。
我们刚刚为Postgres构建了流量控制。你可以按查询、凭据、标签来隔离，精确控制任何应用在集群中能使用的资源。这样智能体就能在你的数据集上工作，并且你知道如果它们做任何影响性能的事情，就会被终止。
这样智能体就能在你的数据集上工作，并且你知道如果它们做任何影响性能的事情，就会被终止。同样，在做模式变更时，我们会监控查询是否变慢。如果出现复制延迟，我们会在系统中增加背压，减缓进程。
在做模式变更时，我们会监控查询是否变慢。如果出现复制延迟，我们会在系统中增加背压，减缓进程。我们很快地过一下刚才演示中的各个阶段，关于指令方面。我们使用平台原语来缩小指令范围，告诉智能体该做什么。
我们经过一个开发过程，让智能体表明它们需要做什么，然后它们进入更传统的开发流程：分支、部署、回滚。这些都是需要智能体自主管理的原语，智能体需要能监控自己工作的状态。
它们需要监控自己工作的状态。一个复杂的后端仍然把这些消息提炼成提示。现在，这不再是人类浏览网页、看图表、找关联，而是基础设施必须为智能体提供非常精准的信息，让它们采取行动。
基础设施必须为智能体提供非常精准的信息，让它们采取行动。好的基础设施把专业知识转化为原语。我们PlanetScale虽然是小公司，但拥有几百年的数据库经验。现在我们通过工具把这些经验传递下去。
我们把这些经验通过工具传递下去。好的基础设施把专业知识转化为原语。我们PlanetScale虽然是小公司，但拥有几百年的数据库经验。现在我们把这些经验传递下去。
我们把系统构建到人们的智能体上，这样他们就能极其快速地构建。这扩展了一种新的工作方式。我们以前从未能为客户编写代码。
但现在我们可以指导他们的智能体去做正确的事情，而且我们能非常安全地进行这种改变。我们正在减少智能体所需的权力，对吧？如果你只是把它们扔给日志流和大量数据，它们可能会做错事。
把事情搞砸，然后我们就进入开发阶段。这是目前最热门的讨论点，就是开发阶段。所以我不用深入太多，这是行业现在非常擅长的事情，用智能体。
但隔离验证确保数据被正确访问。它们不能直接有生产权限去给你的客户发邮件之类的。然后是部署。部署在新的基础设施平台上需要是一个受控环境，
智能体可以在其中排队，并行工作，如果那是安全的话，平台保障安全。如果需要顺序执行，那就串行。对吧？我们可能在重新分片或故障转移时阻塞Schema更改。
所有这些都需要平台指令。现在，像这样长时间的状态更改需要背压。我们会暂缓、回推负载、减少正在做的事情，比如schema更改，以响应实时流量模式。
这让智能体在运行中更安全。它们需要观察自己的更改并验证所做的事情。监控闭环，对吧？赋予智能体评估影响的能力，或者当异常触发，说明你搞坏了生产，就回滚。
所以系统必须把跨越复杂基础设施系统的每一个更改与发生了什么、谁做的、哪个智能体做了更改联系起来。
这就是我们在产品中有各种可审计点的原因，这样你能快速了解发生了什么，其他智能体可以在涌现系统中观察变化。
每次你改变基础设施，我们背后运行的数千个服务现在都有了新的涌现行为。我们需要理解并追踪这些，生产行为成为下一步指令。
我们刚刚改变的将产生整个技术栈的知识和洞察，去指导下一批苏醒并执行任务的智能体。每个阶段都遵循同样的模式。我们把复杂的事情隐藏在自动化后面，
这样智能体就能调用那些自动化，利用各个部分来完成它们需要的不同任务。我们把专业知识变成了离散的工具。所以智能体的未来不仅仅是更聪明的模型，
那一定会发生。但即使模型不再变得更聪明，作为一个行业，我们还有很多要构建，让智能体能够对真实动态系统进行操作。第一天极其容易。第一天一切大多正常。
真正的是持续修剪、演进、维护和照料这个几乎像活体操作系统的生产环境，智能体未来需要与之协作。所以基础设施，好的基础设施，才是让智能体运作的关键。
好的基础设施让智能体得以运作。这就是我的演讲。非常感谢大家的到来。